what has been a painful but formative
experience in your life
or what's the flavor the shape of your
pain that fuels you i mean honestly the
the
first thing that jumped to mind is my
own like battles against myself to to
get my work done because it affects
everything when i i just took five years
in this book and granted it's a it's a
beast like i i probably would have taken
two or three years but it didn't need to
take five and that was
a lot of not just you know not just that
i'm not working instead i'm i'm over
researching i'm making it i'm adding in
things i shouldn't because i'm
perfectionist you know being a
perfectionist about like oh i learned
that now i want to get it in there i
know i'm going to end up cutting it
later just you know or or i over outline
you know something you know until you
know trying to get it perfect when i
know that's not possible she's making a
lot of immature kind of am i like i know
i'm not actually that much of a writing
amateur i've written including my old
blog i've been a writer for 15 years i
know what i'm doing i could advise other
writers really well
and yet i do a bunch of amateur things
that i know while i'm doing them isn't i
know i'm being an amateur so
that a it it it hurts the actual product
it makes you know it b it wastes your
vet your precious time
c
when you're mad at yourself when you're
in a
negative you know self-defeating spiral
it almost inevitably
will you'll be less good to others like
you know i'll just just i used to you
know early on in my now marriage
um one of the things we always used to
do is i used to plan mystery dates you
know new york city great great place for
this i'd find some weird little
adventure for us you know it could be
anything
and i wouldn't tell her what it was i
said i'm reserving you for thursday
night you know at seven okay and it was
such a fun part of our relationship
started writing this book and got into a
really bad you know personal space where
it was like in my head i was like i
can't do anything until this is done you
know like no and i and i just stopped
like ever valuing like
like joy of any kind like i was like no
i i no that's when i'm done and and that
that's a trap or very quickly you know
you know because i always think you know
think it's going to be a six months away
but actually five years later i'm like
wow i really wasn't living fully and for
five years is not we don't live very
long like you talk about your prime
decades like that's like a sixth of my
prime years like wow like that's a huge
loss so to me that was excruciating and
you know and and it was a bad um
pattern a very unproductive unhelpful
pattern for me which is i'd wake up in
the morning in this great mood
great mood every morning wake up
thrilled to be awake have the whole day
ahead of me i'm gonna get so much work
done today and
but you know first i'm gonna do all
these other things and it's all going to
be great and then i end up kind of
failing for the day um with those goals
usually sometimes miserably sometimes
only partially
and then
i get in bed probably a couple hours
later than i want to and that's when all
the
real reality hits me suddenly
so much regret so much anxiety furious
in myself wishing i could take a time
machine back three months six months a
year um or just even to the beginning of
that day
and
uh just tossing and turning now i mean
this is a very bad place that's what i
said suffering real procrastinators
suffer in a very serious way so look i i
you know i know this probably sounds
like a lot of like first world problems
and it is but it's real suffering as
well like it's um
so to me it's like
it's painful because
you're not being uh you're not being as
good a friend or a spouse or whatever as
you could be you're also not treating
yourself very well you're usually not
being very healthy in these moments you
know you're often and you're not being
i'm not being good to my readers so it's
just a lot of this um
and it's like it feels like it's one
small tweak away sometimes it's like
that's what i said it's like if you just
suddenly are just doing that nine to
twelve and you get in that habit
everything else falls into place the all
of this reverses
so
if i feel hopeful but it's like it is a
i have not figured i haven't fixed the
boat yet i i have some good duct tape
though and you also don't want to
romanticize it because it is true that
some so some of the greats in history
especially writers suffer from all the
same stuff like they they weren't quite
able i mean
you might only write for
two or three hours a day but the rest of
the day is often spent you know like
kind of tortured by well right this is
the irrational thing is if i if and this
goes for a lot of people's jobs people
especially who work for themselves
you'd be shocked how much you could wake
up at nine
or eight or seven or whatever get to
work and stop at one but you're really
focused in those hours one or two
and
do 25 really focused hours of stuff
product stuff a week and then there's
112 waking hours in the week right so
we're talking about 80 something hours
of free time
you can live you know if you're just
really focused in your you know yin and
yang of your time and that's what that's
my goal is black and white time i've
really focused time and then totally
like
clean conscience free time
right now neither it's a lot of gray
it's a lot of i shouldn't be working but
i'm not oh i'm wasting this time this is
bad and that's just massive so if you
can just get really good at
uh the black and the white so you just
wake up and it's just like full work and
then i think a lot of people could have
like all this free time but instead i'll
do those same three hours it's like you
said i'll do them really late at night
or whatever after having tortured myself
the whole day and not had any fun it's
not like i'm having fun
um i call it the dark playground by the
way which is where you are when you know
you should be working but you're doing
something else it's
you're doing something fun on paper but
it's it's never it feels awful and so
yeah i spend a lot of time in the dark
and you know you shouldn't be doing it
and you still do it and yeah it's it's
not clean conscious fun it's bad it's
it's toxic um and i think that it's
there's something about you know you're
draining yourself all the time and if
you just did your focused hours and then
if you actually have good clean fun fun
can be anything reading a book can be
hanging out with someone it can be
really fun you can go and do something
cool in the city you know
that is critical it's you're recharging
some part of your psyche there and i
think it makes it easier to actually
work the next day and i say this from
the experiences when i have had you know
good stretches it's like
it's you you're you know what it is it's
like you feel like you're fist pounding
one part of your brain is just pounding
the other part like you're like you're
like we got it like like we we treated
we treat ourselves well like is how
you're internally feeling like i treat
myself and it's like yeah i know it's
work time and then later you're like now
it's play time and it's like okay back
to work because and you're in this very
healthy like parent-child relationship
in your head versus like this constant
conflict and like the kid doesn't
respect the parent parent hates the kid
like yeah
you